any sport we're seeing the emergence of
bosses seem so dominant in their games
that it has become every other team's
goal to take them down for example we
have SKT three-time world champions in
League of Legends optic gaming in Halo
and og who are the reigning kings of
dota 2 energy really are the bosses of
the mages but I got us thinking who are
the most memorable bosses in the history
of video games here are our picks for
the top 10 coming in at number 10 is the
Didact from halo 4 the Didact purpose is
to enslave the universe to do with evil
bidding not only that but during the
epic fight to destroy him
Cortana sacrifices herself to save you
Master Chief
leaving you with one of the most
emotional cutscenes in gaming history so
how do we get out of here
I'm not coming with you this time what
number 9 is the lich king from world of
warcraft our vista lich king is not only
one of the Warcraft universes most
famous villains but one of Wow's most
difficult raid bosses
four Wrath of the Lich King players who
experienced him pre nerf the lich king
remains one hell of an experience even
nearly a decade later finally defeating
the lich king is one of gaming's most
memorable moments
we blocked it
[Music]
coming in at number eight is orange sign
and smell from Dark Souls for those that
plagued Dark Souls
this isn't need an explanation for those
fat didn't this duo was so insanely
difficult to be that it left us throwing
our controllers coming in at number
seven is Deborah Ross from Final Fantasy
7
Sephiroth remains Final Fantasies most
iconic villain over two decades after
his first appearance his boss fight does
not disappoint spanning several forms
that test your party while being backed
by the most famous boss team in
videogame history one winged angel
[Music]
number six on our list is Mike Tyson
from Mike Tyson's punch-out because well
it's Mike Tyson coming in at number five
is Master Hand from Super Smash Bros
Master Hand has been around since the
first game and he's been epic ever since
first he creates the super smash bros
universe makes your favorite characters
fight each other and then tries to pick
you up what a dick coming in at number
four is the law from Metal Gear Solid
after raising snake loving him and
teaching him everything she knows you
are faced with the emotional task of
defeating her kill we knew
[Music]
there's no smoke from one thought and
one stink
[Music]
easily one of the most satisfying get
emotional boss battles of all time
coming in at number three on our list is
GLaDOS from Portal this famous AI
trapped you and forces you to solve
puzzles all while manipulating you
insulting you and then trying to kill
you shutting up her robotic voice is
ever so satisfying and ever so memorable
[Music]
scientist human doctor you're not even a
full time employee number two on our
list is Ganondorf from The Legend of
Zelda we all know him he's always
ruining your plans and keeping you away
from Zelda not to mention he just looks
awesome on top of it Ganon has been a
problem since 1986 and he continues to
be a problem today he's not leaving your
memories anytime soon
coming in at number one on our list is
Bowser from Super Mario I don't think
this one needs much explanation on top
of him simply being an iconic character
he is a challenge fighting through the
difficult levels only to have to say
Sauser at the end is more than just a
boss battle but a rite of passage for
generation of gamers Bowser was their
first boss battle and he continues to
kick ass til this day does it get much
more memorable than that and there you
have it
those were our picks for the top 10 most
memorable bosses and video games if you
agree with our list be sure to give it a
thumbs up and if you disagree with our
list come at me and leave a comment
below
[Music]